Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 5th,
2018 what's going on?
How are you?
Oh,
that's phenomenal.
Isn't that wonderful?
Hey everybody,
I don't know if you've heard,
I don't know if you've been on a TV or near a TV.
I don't know if you stream your thoughts at this point through some sort of
algorithm on a worldwide network.
Um,
I dunno if you've heard this is for Americans only by the way,
people from the United States of America,
everybody else,
you know,
if you're in Australia,
just go stick a beat on something and fucking eat it during this time.
All right?
Cause this has nothing to do with you and that giant fucking can of Foster's
lager,
whatever the fuck it is that none of you constrict down there.
It's why you stick it in a little fucking powder keg like you just trying to get
rid of it,
sending it our way.
Right.
Um,
that beer,
that's the Busch light of Australia anyways.
I've never had one.
I just,
I just judge it by the size of the can.
I'm like,
oh,
what's that fucking good.
Why are you giving it away by the bucketful anyways
for the people that this podcast truly represents.
And that would be the greatest people on this planet,
the people of the United States of America.
Um,
particularly the white people.
Fuck with you going on.
Trump on here.
Sorry,
I'm reading a Trump speech.
Um,
it's a first draft of a Trump speech.
evidently tomorrow,
and I didn't know this,
I don't know if you aware of this,
but I was not aware that tomorrow is evidently a very important day in politics.
Quite possibly the most important
political day in history.
And you know something I had no idea,
but thank God all of these celebrities have taken time out of their day to let
me know how important it is.
You know what I mean?
Just when you think of celebrity cannot give more of themselves on screen after
they'd been driven over in a golf cart and add their fucking hair foof to buy
some fucking poor bastard in a trailer,
right.
Food,
poof.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Thank God you know something.
And I've been so inspired by all of these celebrities letting me know what is
going on in my country.
You know what I mean?
Why would I listen to,
to,
to people who I don't know are in that business for living?
Why would I listen to them when I can listen to somebody who's on a sitcom?
MMM.
And you know what?
I've been so inspired.
I actually think that going to,
uh,
I'm going to you,
oh,
look who's calling in here.
Little face time here.
My kiddo.
Hey Buddy.
Hi.
Hey need,
I'm doing the podcast.
Oh,
Tom Lily recording right now.
You guys are on the podcast.
Say Hi Dada.
Hi Sweetheart.
Hey.
Do you know tomorrow is a very important election day?
I did.
I'd be getting text messages round the clock about it.
I had no idea.
And then somebody,
uh,
the third lead in a x man movie,
let me know that I need to get out there and vote.
I got an email from an actor as well.
Yeah.
I don't know why they're doing that.
I have a bad feeling that it's going to drive it the other way.
I was just in,
I was just in a a car service coming over from the airport and the guy goes,
I'm voting no red tomorrow.
All red.
All right.
I gotta get back to the podcast.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye Buddy.
Bye Sweetheart.
All right,
I'll see you in a minute.
Okay.
Um,
yeah.
Anyways,
so what I think I'm going to do,
I am going to loan my podcast celebrity to try and inspire some of you to get
out there tomorrow.
Get out there and vote.
And when I say vote,
I don't mean go out and decide who you think is the right candidate.
I want you to go out there and vote.
Who for who?
I want you to vote for.
Okay.
I'm loaning my podcast celebrity and I feel like more so than that,
I'm actually going to be honest with you
as a person in your public ears rather than just being like trying to be like
non,
you know,
criminal here and just say get out there and vote.
I want you to vote.
Who,
who I want you to vote for.
Okay?
I don't know who to vote for him.
Maybe.
Maybe somebody that hosts a game show could tell me.
I watch CNN and Fox News all the time.
I'm informed.
I read the Sunday New York Times.
Shut up.
Jesus.
Do these fucking people understand that there's,
there's engineers and doctors,
you know I'm too stupid.
Name another smart job.
Veterinarian.
The guy who knows how to hook up your fucking cable.
I mean these are smart people.
They know it's an important fucking election.
They know who they're voting for.
All right?
I got a bad feeling that they're going to get this wrong the same way they got
the election wrong.
You know,
I actually think
that have celebrities wanted this blue wave.
They should shut up.
Cause do you know people who are on the red side are also watching this shit?
It's like you're broadcasting to the Japanese during World War II when you're
going to attack.
Why would you do that?
You gotta get on your own frequency,
right?
Oh,
who should I vote for?
Maybe 10 year ro could tell me.
Um,
hey,
I liked that guy's movies.
Maybe I like his political choices.
MMM.
Do you remember back in the day when you just,
you know,
you didn't bring up politics and you didn't bring up religion and you sat there
and you eat your fucking cheese sandwich,
you know,
and you just said that was it.
Every fucking put,
you know,
you gotta get out there and vote.
And by vote,
I mean vote who I'm gonna vote for.
Oh my God,
what is wrong with this country?
How come everybody doesn't see it the way I see it?
MMM.
Anyways,
having said that,
I usually vote,
but I'm going to be here in New York and I didn't file for the absentee thing,
you know?
So whoever's not liking this should be happy that I just cancelled out my vote.
You know,
and one of the most important elections of all time.
And you know why it's important because the same five corporations that have the
money on all the horses in the race this time decided to just put it on one side
of the ball evidently.
So we will move towards a more prosperous future.
For the middle class
because someone's finally going to regulate the banks again.
Is that what we're voting for?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Hey,
you know what?
I'm going to loan,
I'm going to loan my podcast celebrity right now and I'm going to solve the
problems of the Middle East right now.
First thing I would do,
I would go over there.
I would tell everybody to grow up.
Okay.
As far as I can tell you all worship the same thing.
Um,
no,
this is what I would do.
I would,
uh,
I would break up with Iraq as the first thing I would do.
I would just sit down and just say,
listen,
I wreck,
I'm not happy.
Yes,
this isn't working out.
I know,
I know.
I came in like gang busters.
I moved in within a week with this whole relationship,
just moved way too quickly.
All right.
And I just,
you know,
it's not that I,
I love you,
but I don't love you in a way that makes me want to stay
and I would just get the fuck out.
You can keep the Starbucks and all these fucking things,
right.
All right.
Switch over to solar power.
I would do all of this on the same day.
By the way,
in my world,
you can actually do this.
Switch over to solar power.
Take that lunatic over a Tesla.
You know,
he,
uh,
he looks like the guy,
Ian Mcshane,
if he had a nervous breakdown or so,
I don't know what the fuck that fucking guy,
right.
I would just all electric all the fucking time.
Right?
I'd have a big campaign where I bring back the electric slide and everybody
fucking enough mouth breathers would do it and they would get behind it and then
we're not no more money to the Middle East.
All right.
For Oil.
Then they'd all go bankrupt and the second we leave,
they go back to kicking the shit out of each other.
You know what I mean?
The same way,
when Russia left Eastern Europe,
everybody was happy for about three days and then they all started killing each
other again.
They were like,
oh yeah,
where,
where are we?
That's right.
God said we're better.
Right?
They just went right back to that shit.
See you leave.
Yeah,
you got look fucking solar power and all that fucking shit going on.
I don't know if he knows about the Middle East.
Middle East always reminded me of,
there was used to be this store in the uh,
south shore plaza that I used to go to before they did the remodel.
You know,
when it was all brown and seventies looking,
I swear to God,
I think the floor was made out of vinyl,
some sort of rubber.
Anyways,
they used to have these little kiosks in the middle of all these big stores,
almost like a,
like little moons to these giant fucking planets of stores.
And one of them was called Wickson sticks and all they sold was candles.
And even as a little kid I was like,
how are they stay and
open?
Like that's all they sell.
You know,
if people ever stopped fucking or raw doing Voodoo,
like these people are going to be in trouble.
So I look at like the Middle East,
like they like a giant Wickson sticks.
Like where Wickson sticks,
just,
just sold candles.
They just sell an oil.
That's their main thing.
If you stop buying their oil,
they don't have any money.
They don't have any money.
They can't finance a fucking military.
Right?
Meanwhile,
they can't have a dangerous species as pets.
So that's too far right there.
They slowly go out of fucking business.
We're over here with their fucking a,
I don't know,
fucking electric cars and shit.
Not saying it's cleaner for the environment,
but it gets you out of that shit.
If elected tomorrow,
ladies,
gentlemen,
I will,
I will present a three day plan to get us out of the Middle East
and off of oil that would be implemented immediately
despite the crushing effects on the economy.
I'm sorry,
I'm just,
I don't need somebody who was in fucking third rock from the sun,
you know,
talking to me about this.
But,
you know,
at the end of the day,
I am not voting.
I would have voted,
but,
um,
I'm just on the road.
So what am I supposed to do?
Well built.
You could apply for an absentee ballot.
Um,
well I would,
but the people that I vote for never win
cause they aid the Democrats,
the Republican Party.
I vote for those lunatics.
There's people that are like,
I don't know man.
If we voted for this guy and he got in,
I don't know,
either things would get better or everything would be on fire.
Like those are the people that I vote for.
So maybe I shouldn't fall.
Maybe I'm one of those people.
We'll be right back with podcasts.
Celebrities who don't vote.
MMM.
As a podcast celebrities.
I just like saying that,
that makes me feel important.
Um,
speaking of important,
I have a couple of important announcements to make.
Um,
I'm going to be at Madison Square Garden on Wednesday,
the day after the election.
I think I'm still going to be like telling people what they should vote for.
That's how full of myself I am.
The day after the election.
You know what you should've done.
You know,
like somebody calls up a sports show the day after their team fucking losers.
Um,
all right.
important announcement.
Uh,
my patrion page,
www.patrion.com/birth five bucks a month.
Every month you get two episodes of uninformed with me and old Joey roses.
Um,
I got a,
uh,
let's see,
live from the live Monday morning podcasts that I filmed.
I didn't find any live studio on its pocket.
We'll do it live in Phoenix or you can download that from the patrion app to
stream,
um,
that in new uninformed episodes or download directly to your phone.
I have behind the scenes and a,
the forum behind the scenes backstage I should say.
And uh,
I have some helicopter video and I'm just going to keep adding to that every
month.
It's at www.patrion.com/bar.
MMM,
that's it.
What else do I have?
I think that was it.
Um,
other than that,
I went up and,
yeah,
I visited my family back east and I went to the Patriots Green Bay packers game.
Obviously was very excited with the outcome of that game.
I was nervous because Aaron Rodgers is such a fucking beast and uh,
yeah,
I was nervous about our defense against them.
And,
uh,
you know,
played a little Ben don't break in the red zone.
Uh,
you kind of had all day to pass,
so most of the game,
but when it counted,
we got in his fucking grill and made it happen.
Um,
and I had great seats,
you know,
I have to tell on Jimmy Kimmel that I sit up,
up top with the fucking real people actually got into one of those boxes,
no sitting right in the front fucking row.
MMM.
They had the window open and shit.
It was great.
So I was like cold.
But then when I walked into the back near the food,
I was all warm like those in somebody's living room.
I got treated like an absolute king.
So I want to thank the Patriots.
Um,
when we got the whole trip,
I got to see the,
uh,
the trophies.
I got to talk to Andre Tippett.
I mean,
it was,
it was incredible.
It was fucking incredible.
And then I watched arguably two of the greatest quarterbacks of all time.
I mean,
one of them is the greatest quarterback of all time.
And then the other one,
I don't know,
you know,
what are we going to put in?
But he's the only halfway done,
you know,
he's just fucking kicking the shit out of everybody.
He's on track.
Right.
And he's on track to be what top five every has got gotta be,
you know,
I bet if he,
if he wasn't doing what he was doing in Green Bay,
you know,
if he was doing it in a different city like New York,
he probably already be there.
You got to work twice as hard,
twice as hard in green bay,
I feel like.
But can you imagine me in the greatest quarterback of all time?
And you're in Buffalo,
New York,
Green Bay,
Wisconsin.
Like how long would it take people to notice?
Um,
we're taking collars?
No,
it was an amazing game.
And,
um,
is that,
that's maybe the third time I've seen Aaron Rodgers play live.
He just always,
he's one of those guys where he starts to run and then he can throw the fucking
ball,
you think.
All right,
he's going to run for like eight.
Yah,
we did.
He just got 30 yards.
Like how good he is at that is,
it's,
it's like drives you up the fucking wall when you're watching your team cause
you'll like tackle.
Okay.
They got him go get,
he slipped away.
Now I've got to check on him before he gets a pasta,
throws it down the goddamn field.
I bet people like bitching at some of our quarterbacks.
It's like,
dude,
that aid them.
They'd been running around back there for like six seconds.
Like something should have happened by now.
They shouldn't still have to be covering a receiver.
MMM.
But anyways,
uh,
I kinda called it before the game.
I kind of feel on Josh Gordon was going to have a breakout game,
which I feel like he did.
I couldn't tell and I wasn't watching any sort of broadcast.
Looks like you've jammed his fingers or something on two plays in a row.
He was looking at his hands.
I hope he's all right.
And then that Patterson do just took over before the half,
just unstoppable.
Just handing the ball off door.
This hybrid running back wide receiver.
I mean,
how perfect is that for Bella checks offense.
Um,
so here we go with six and two,
but fucking Kansas City won again.
So there,
what this seven and one,
I don't fucking know.
I got a kid now.
I have no idea.
So as a right now,
we would play Kansas City at home,
provided we got to the AFC championship game and uh,
tell you that would be,
that'd be a tall order trying to beat those guys two times a one year.
Um,
once again,
people freaking out about my homes.
He threw a ball like 90 yards.
Oh,
you mean like Doug Williams did 30 years ago?
Sorry.
Um,
I've never seen anything like this.
Alright.
Lsu versus Alabama.
Oh,
Jesus.
that one hurt.
Oh,
did that one hurt?
I was like,
Alabama hasn't fucking played anybody.
Let's look at their fucking schedule.
Right.
Cause this is what I was doing.
I was like,
you know something.
Yeah.
Even though our fucking best defensive players going to be on the bench for the
first fucking half,
I feel like we're going to hang with them.
Then the other kid comes in.
Maybe he can,
uh,
you know,
tip the scale and Lsus favor.
That did not happen.
Can I spell Alabama?
Alabama also scheduled 2018.
Let's listen to these powerhouses that Alabama has played a Mississippi state.
That's not bad.
Auburn.
Oh,
this is what they have left.
I'm sorry.
Sorry.
Hang on a sec.
Hang on a second.
Auburn.
They play Auburn every day of every fucking Thanksgiving though.
All right.
They played Louisville.
Yeah,
one 50,
one to 14.
Then they played Mississippi,
then they played Louisiana,
Lafayette.
Then they played Missouri.
Uh,
or whatever.
I think I'm fucking up these.
None of these teams are ranked.
They played Arkansas state.
They played Texas a and m not Alabama's fault that Texas a and M is not good
right now.
Then they played Arkansas.
Not Their fault.
They played Tennessee.
They played Missouri.
This is Lsu is the first fucking rank team they played all year.
So I'm thinking like,
well,
they're finally fucking planes.
Somebody.
Let's see what happens.
And they went in there and they just fucking kicked him right in the deck.
I mean,
it just,
it offense couldn't do shit.
The defense just dominated.
Um,
it's,
it's like they just stuck a rag in their mouth and fucking wrap some duct tape
right around of all fit and just repeatedly kicked him in the nuts slowly for
four straight quarters,
um,
29 to nothing.
So all those haters out there,
you know.
Yeah.
They don't play shit,
but it's not their fault.
It's not their fault.
And everybody kind of sucks that they're playing,
but then when they do play a number three team,
they fucking destroyed them.
So they got Mississippi state and then the biggest challenge of the year,
they play citadel.
Yeah.
And then they got a Auburn and then for some reason there's a game on the 1st of
December.
I would have thought that that was the last one.
They're playing Georgia.
So they,
they got some teams come on up.
Not really.
Um,
but let's just say there'll be nice and rested for when they played for yet
another championship,
but you know,
something as much as people bitch about that,
you know,
they're easy scheduled,
then they get in the championship game.
And more times than not,
they win,
you know,
as opposed to Ohio state.
I remember a few years ago,
they fucking,
they Penn state beat them straight up and then also won the big 10
championships.
And for some reason Penn state didn't get in,
but Ohio state did.
And then Ohio state went down there and got that fucking shorts yanked down.
Um,
I'm in way over my head right now.
I don't even know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Um,
but I can just tell you as a podcast celebrity,
your vote on who should be,
who should make the Ncaa College football playoff is extremely important.
It's extremely important that this Saturday coming up is one of the most
important Saturdays in college football history and who would know better?
Yeah.
Then his celebrity podcasts.
Oh,
that sounds better,
doesn't it?
I'm going to have to put that on my fucking,
mmm.
[inaudible]
I guess concerned for that on my Wikipedia page.
Comedian,
actor,
celebrity podcast or,
uh,
please don't put that on there.
Well,
I've already said to do it.
So now it's 2000 and I was done.
Um,
anyways,
um,
so I'm hanging in here in New York,
uh,
going to do my little tune up,
show tonight,
bounce around some clubs here in New York.
Uh,
looking forward to that.
And then,
uh,
I got my big shoe on,
um,
on Wednesday,
so I'm just sitting here and then I got,
I got three shows in Chicago.
Yeah.
Um,
at the Chicago theater on Thursday,
Friday and Saturday.
And then all freckles is fucking done for the year I've done for the year.
So I mean,
okay.
Uh,
no,
I mean I got some local shows then I'm doing,
but um,
and I will not be doing shit again until I go out to eastern Europe,
which I already made fun of on this podcast.
When are we announcing those dates?
I don't know.
I think I just pictured the hedge.
I just pick the headshot they going to use or something to that nature.
So any day now
and um,
oh,
you know what,
fuck this.
I'm just going to tell you this.
I'm going to tell you the fucking cities.
I'm going to be it,
but I'm not going to tell you the dates.
All I'm going to do is tell you that it fucking,
it.
It starts
on,
um,
what is it?
January 2nd.
All right,
here we go.
Let's see if I can find it here.
Oh,
Ho,
Ho.
Bailey.
When a,
you're going,
okay,
so fucking eastern Europe.
Well,
where the fuck are they?
Yeah.
Oh,
that's not it.
Yeah.
Oh,
why is that?
That's a tough fucking motherfucker.
What,
why aren't you showing me?
What the Fuck I want?
All right.
You know what?
I'm just gonna put an Eastern Europe.
How about just Europe?
Okay.
Eastern Europe.
Ah,
right.
All right.
I'm just going to,
I'm going to be in Prague,
Vienna,
Berlin,
Warsaw,
Latvia.
I mean,
in a way that is Lithuania,
Astonia,
Bulgaria,
Cologne,
Munich,
often back Germany,
Budapest,
Hungary.
I might've read those kind of backwards.
Um,
that's going to be from January 3rd until a Sunday,
January 13th,
10 days.
And I'm bringing Paul Versey with me.
Yeah.
And he's going to go over there with his fucking blue Yankee hat and his fucking
joy.
Dude.
Eastern Europe,
Jordan,
sixes
over over.
We uh,
I'm actually a came in town early because we had a surprise birthday party for
Paul.
And um,
when I tell you like,
you know when you go to those things and like the person's kind of figured it
out and then they try to act like the surprise and you know that the not like
Versie legit had no fucking clue.
He was coming down the stairs and I could tell the way he was talking,
it was at this restaurant,
the way he was talking to this guy,
I was like,
oh my God,
this guy has like no clue.
And then hours I got like nervous for a second.
Like is he going to have like a fucking heart attack?
What if he just breaks down and starts crying?
Like I always there,
you guys were like,
you know,
just gets really fucking awkward.
I got,
I got like really I don't like doing that to people.
You know what I mean?
You know,
let them know what's going on.
Yeah,
he just came,
walked around the corner.
We all just go sell prize.
And he did like a fucking doubletake put his hand up to his face and then just
walked out of the room for a second.
But it was funny.
Everybody laughed and then he came back
and uh,
I'll met God.
We had a great time.
That's like this whiskey tasting thing.
It was just amazing.
It was fucking amazing.
And this guy was giving us all this whole,
okay
fucking history lesson on whiskey to a bunch of comedians.
So it's like,
we're in class with this subject we always wanted to take,
but at the end of the day,
we're all class clowns.
Everybody's trying to outdo each other.
And this Guy Ethan,
who did the,
the tour just handled it like a champ.
You know,
we gave him shit a little bit.
He gave a shit back.
Um,
it was,
oh,
it's just such a fucking great time.
Then he had somebody they can roll in cigars.
It was really,
uh,
it was amazing.
And then I went up to the Patriots game.
Yeah,
you know,
this,
this is what it's like people to be a celebrity pie.
I'm going to start with that joke.
All right.
Anyways,
so I'm back here in New York and,
uh,
I was watching today on ESPN.
Yeah.
Um,
they said the Lakers hit a new low and the Lebron era,
it's like the just fucking started.
It seems like a month into it.
Magic Johnson said they're on a two year plan.
The first year is going to be rough and then they're going to clear all this cap
space.
So they're going to buy a bunch of people and make a run and fucking,
uh,
yeah.
Oh,
a golden state.
I mean,
the guy said that.
He said,
that's what I'm going to do.
I don't understand why ESPN is trying to make me act like this is like this big
failure and Luke Walton needs to be fired.
They said it's a two year plan.
We're barely fucking,
not even two months into this
Jesus Christ,
he fucking ESPN.
I swear to God,
they're worse than CNN and Fox.
So I don't watch any of those channels.
I just actually tell,
tell me who won the game.
Get me all fucking anxious.
Um,
we had a,
bt was Luke Walton.
Uh,
they,
they said it wasn't,
you know,
okay.
It didn't concern his job,
but could it Ben,
his kidneys,
sorry.
Anyways,
um,
I actually been going to the gym out here in New York
and uh,
you know,
I had a little bit of set,
a little bit of a setback with my shoulder.
Now I'm back.
MMM.
The person I was working with was telling me when I could do like 120 pounds,
like 10 times on the lat pull down with the weight that I'm at.
I could attempt to do a pull up.
My shoulder would be,
but you know,
one to three,
which means I would just do one.
And uh,
you know,
I took a few days off,
I tried to come back where I left off,
I was up to 110 pounds and it felt a little tweak.
I fucking stopped immediately shut the whole thing down.
Ice My shoulder and I was fine,
but I had to go back down to about 75 pounds.
Just these fucking rotator cuffs to such,
they're so delicate.
You know what I mean?
It's like a,
you don't like what?
Like someone who's is a needy self centered asshole,
like their group of friends.
It's just like,
uh,
I don't know what their deal is.
They're like a,
it's like this entourage of people.
Like that's Kinda like what a,
your rotator cuff is like that person,
you know,
if your shoulder muscles are a bunch of different people built,
what are you talking about?
I don't know.
I'm just trying to feel fucking time.
Let me read some advertising here.
How about that?
Huh?
Did I,
did I copy and paste the advertising?
I don't think I did.
Here we go.
My age is probably going to give me shit for reading those fucking names of
those cities.
I mean,
what am I supposed to do?
I've been,
I've been Prehype in it for awhile.
Okay.
By the way that my eastern European tour is going to be one of the most
important standup tours
and the history of eastern European standup tours by bald right ahead of males
who grew up in Massachusetts,
south of Boston.
All right.
Oh my bookie.
Everybody a sure watch footballs far more.
Would you like to have a little bit,
you know it,
but it's more entertaining when you have some action on the games.
Guys,
you've heard me talk about this for weeks and some of you are still on the
sidelines,
like a bunch of Mary's.
Uh,
whether you're an expert or a rookie,
you should be betting my bookie that my bookie,
if you're the kind of guy that likes to bet a little and when a lot like playing
the numbers on roulette,
you can create a big par Lait pick three teams to win and it be hit all three.
You could turn $100 into 600 bucks.
I never do the parlays that's like fucking doing a murder with somebody else.
You know,
somebody's gonna rat somebody up.
You know what I mean?
I do individual bets.
Um,
anyways,
there's just so much to bet on.
Playoff baseball,
basketball,
hockey,
primetime fights in more.
Also,
make sure to follow bet at,
oh,
sorry.
At bet my bookie on Twitter or Instagram,
they personally respond to every mention in DM.
Not to mention they've given away nearly $10,000 in free money to their fellow,
to their followers this football season.
You'll be the first to know as soon as the odds and PR on props or posted a log
onto my bookie right now.
Don't miss out on your left opportunity to collect the industry's biggest bonus.
Use Promo Code [inaudible] and you'll get your first deposit matched 100%.
That's Promo Code.
Burb you are,
are you play,
you win,
you get paid or you lose,
you pay.
And maybe your girlfriend breaks up with you.
Just giving you all the possibilities here.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
I don't read all this shit.
Frame Bridge.
Yeah.
Um,
if you've been listening to this show,
you've heard me talk about frame bridge,
the most important framed bridges.
Yeah.
Tomorrow on Tuesday.
Uh,
they make it super easy and affordable.
To frame your favorite things from art.
I just immediately pictured somebody framing their Dick for some reason from art
prints and posters to the photos sitting on your phone.
Here's how it worked.
Just go to [inaudible] Dot Com and upload your photo or they'll send you
packaging to safely mail in your
male and your physical pieces.
Yeah,
and we're back to dex again.
Um,
preview your item online in any frame style.
Choose your favorite or get free recommendations from their talented designers,
the expert team at frame bridge,
what custom frame your item and delivery your finished piece directly to your
door ready to hang instead of the hundreds you'd pay it a framing store.
Their prices start at just $39 and all the shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their first order@framebridge.com when they
used my code burr get started today.
Frame your photo or send the perfect gift for weddings,
birthdays,
and special events.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and use promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15% off your first order.
Just go to frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Bar.
Hey,
frame which.com Promo Code Berm.
Yeah.
All right.
There's three left.
Let's take a break here.
Shall We?
From reading your fucking eyes hurt.
Um,
okay.
Let me see if feminist.
Yeah.
Cheerleaders.
Somebody was saying that they have a problem with cheerleaders.
Should we let our girls be cheerleaders?
Is it time to rethink the rules for NFL cheerleaders?
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
Let's see what day,
what it,
let's see what the fucking problem is.
Yeah.
What is the problem now?
Okay.
40 years ago this month,
a visitor at the Dallas cowboys cheerleading tryouts described as seeing that
was quote as tense as an open casting call for a Broadway production with 150
woman,
the most envied,
celebrated,
and sought after in the country.
Shivering in an overly air conditioned room.
Aw.
That's like being backstage at Letterman.
It was fucking freezing.
Uh,
the women's spoke of starvation diets that had lasted for weeks.
The sounds like when you got a movie premiere premiere coming up,
uh,
the visitor,
a New York Times reporter,
and noted that the cheerleaders were paid next to nothing,
$15 a game.
They had stringent practice schedules as much as five hours a night,
five nights a week.
The only thing I agree with is how little they pay.
They should pay more and they could not appear where alcohol was served at 10
parties of any sort or wear jewelry with the uniforms.
A cowboy cheerleader above all else is beautiful.
The article said at a time when the squad was perhaps the most iconic side's
case.
So what is the fucking problem
for decades later the world made have changed,
but the rules of professional cheerleading appear to be essentially the same.
No.
Okay.
These people,
they don't even know what the fuck they're talking about.
First of all,
cheerleaders,
they used to lead cheers before there was diamond v.
Dot.
The big fucking whatever you call them,
the big fucking flat screens and all the music go,
go shorty and all that shit.
You know,
everybody clap your hands before all of that shit.
They would lead people in chairs,
but then when it became obsolete,
so now what they really are,
is it just sort of dance teams and then one,
there's a stoppage of play.
They'd come out,
oh,
Bobo Bobo.
Break it down,
right?
They just do something.
They just do some shit.
And this is just,
once again,
I swear to God,
this is just,
this is just fucking,
I'm telling you,
like the women who are going to complain about this,
no one's going to ask you to be a cheerleader.
This is like me being concerned with the models at copper tone being like,
are they being,
you know,
tanning is not the most healthy thing.
And in the end it's really,
I'm just jealous because I don't have any pigment and look,
according to the Internet,
like among the Lloyd.
MMM.
Is it time to rethink this?
I don't think I've ever seen with all of the true,
huge fucking gigantic fucking problems out there.
I don't think I've ever seen a time where just like the most frivolous shit gets
kids bumped all the way up to the top.
It's like all those fucking assholes that some our board,
the plane before group one.
Will you just looking at how to fuck did that person get on to people today?
Got On,
not veterans.
No kids not limping.
Somehow got on before.
Everybody else is just like,
what the fuck did they do?
And my buddy just sent me something.
This is going to be the new scam in aviation.
Is everybody just paying money and extra shit just to be able to get on that
fucking plane.
First my buddies,
uh,
Dean del Ray sent me this thing.
It's like five grand a year.
Five fucking grand a year.
You go to the,
you go to your own private terminal at lax and then,
then they take you right to the plane and you get on first.
So you know what?
I decided,
I was like,
you know what?
I'm just going to pack less.
Okay,
well I'm going to be old Billy backpack and my backpack will fit right
underneath my fucking chair.
And then you guys and anybody else who wants to fucking,
you know,
sit there like,
like a,
like a bunch of fucking hyenas trying to get the spoils of a lions kill.
I am.
I'm not fucking doing it.
All right.
I'm going to fucking hang back
and be like,
all right,
I'll you fucking I,
I quit.
Okay.
I did it the right way.
I started in the back of the,
I worked my way up.
I was promised a gold watch and the gold watch was that I was going to get on
first.
Just doesn't fucking exist anymore.
MMM.
Anyways,
what is a,
what the fuck was I talking about?
Oh yes.
So there's all these,
I actually like,
so,
you know,
it's funny,
I just,
I just did with these feminists to doing
right
rather than dealing with overpopulation,
climate change,
fucking uh,
an uh,
deregulated banks.
We're going to tackle cheerleading.
Why?
Because it affects me then.
I love that I went on that fucking rant about people getting on the plane first.
Cause I just showed him just as fucking bad as they are,
you know,
so God bless them.
Let a bitch above a fucking job.
They're never going to be offered.
How fucking full of yourself are you?
Should I let my daughter cheerlead what?
Is she good looking enough?
Should I let my son be the head of the math team?
Well,
did your son get your fucking,
I'm actually making fun of myself here.
You're,
you're fucking animal.
Should I let my kid read out loud on the radio?
Uh,
no bill for the love of God know.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
policy genius.
Everybody.
That was just a little break.
That's what feminists are concerned about now.
Cheerleading.
Yeah.
Hey,
there's this swirl of trash two times the size of Texas,
two miles deep out in the Pacific Ocean.
I don't give a fuck.
Okay.
Pull a pom poms.
Yeah.
Um,
I don't give a shit.
Let's talk about cheerleading.
All right.
Policy genius.
Life Insurance isn't the most enjoyable thing to think about.
Most people don't like thinking about dying.
I can tell you right now,
I've got a life insurance policy and now all of a sudden I,
you know,
I always took a weight off my chest.
It's like I can fucking leave now and,
and nobody's going to have a problem.
And I'm not talking about dying.
I'm talking about going out and getting a pack of smokes and never coming back.
Uh,
but actually having life insurance is a really good feeling as I just said.
Yeah.
I literally feel like I could abandoned my family.
Like that's how relieved I am that I have life insurance.
It's nice to know that if anything were to happen to you,
I immediately pictured a piano.
Did anybody ever bring a piano up with a fucking rope?
Did that really happen?
And why would somebody walk underneath,
um,
anything happen to you?
Your family won't have to start a go fund me to stay afloat.
Well,
here's my question.
What happens if something happens to my family?
What about the guy here?
Huh?
When do I get the fucking put my feet up.
Uh,
motivate your audience.
Talk about your experience with the product slash service.
Choose one to two copy points to rotate into your spot.
Okay.
Um,
well I already told you how much I like life insurance.
I just did it before you guys advertised here.
So I didn't use policy genius,
but you know,
had there I had,
I known that there was a policy genius out there.
I would have used it and would have saved myself a fucking small fortune.
Right.
My loved ones would be in Kavia rather than 200 fish.
Yeah.
Policy Genius is easiest way to get life insurance online and just two minutes.
You can compare quotes from the top insurers to find the best policy for you.
And when you compare quotes,
you save money.
It's that simple.
Policy Genius has helped over 4 million people shop for insurance and placed
over $20 billion in coverage and they don't just make life insurance easy.
They also compare disability insurance,
auto insurance,
and home insurance.
If you care about it,
they cover it.
Call to action.
So if you've been avoiding getting life insurance because it's difficult or
confusing,
I don't get it man.
Give policy genius to try.
Just go to policy genius.com for all your dummies out there.
That's o l I see why GE and I,
u s genius is such a hard word to spell,
isn't it?
Get Your quotes and apply in minutes.
You can do the whole thing on your phone right now.
Policy genius.
Be Easy Way to compare it by Lavan Jerrod's that whole time I was just thinking
about those fucking cheerleader thing.
You know,
I had to starve myself and everything.
You mean make sacrifices?
Well,
get a fucking nutritionist.
You don't have to starve.
You just have to eat foods that fuel your body.
Yeah.
If you consider star,
I like how like you know,
have you ever seen real starving people?
What?
The distended bellies and you can count their fucking rib cage.
Lionel Hampton could come over and play a fucking song on that goddamn torso.
That starving.
All right.
These poor women starved themselves.
The air conditioning is turned on too low.
Just imagine
living in some fucking war torn country and listening to that fucking argument.
I think one of the biggest problems facing women today is the question of
cheerleading.
All right,
helix,
everybody.
Helix.
You ever wake up in the morning?
We'll do.
Yeah.
With regrets of what you've done.
Jesus Christ.
Tell tale heart.
Is your roommate buried underneath your floorboards and your best friend,
Dad,
the cop is coming over a reef laying the terrible decisions you've made the
previous night over and over and over.
Jesus Christ.
Yes.
The kicking,
sweating,
yelling or whatever she did to piss off everyone in the bedroom.
Well,
guess what,
Bud?
Deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
MMM.
Wait a second.
You telling me if I have a nice mattress,
I won't regret decisions I made as a younger man.
This might be the greatest sales pitch I've ever heard in my life.
What else can it do?
I you sick of your dick staring down at your ball bag when you wake up in the
morning.
Wouldn't it be great if it was fucking pointing at the ceiling?
Is it to say there's a fucking raccoon up there?
Be careful.
Um,
anyways,
what the hell am I here?
Yeah.
Deciding to sleep on a shitty mattress is your choice.
But bill,
buying a mattress is so hard.
Where would I ever begin?
Well,
you're in luck buddy,
because he likes sleep.
The Ma,
the mattress I've been yelling at you to buy for almost two years will change
your life.
Go to helix,
sleep.com/bird.
Take their two minutes sleep quiz and the match you to the perfect mattress.
What kind of a creep reads other people's sleep quiz?
Are you naked when you sleep?
Oh yeah.
You,
whether it's on something violent,
um,
it's like Tinder for them for finding a mattress.
All the fun with none of the next morning regrets and misery.
And right now you can get up to a dollar 25 off your mattress order at helix,
sleep.com/bar they have $100 a hundred night trial.
Free shipping at won't send you creepy next day texts.
That's helix
sleep.com/burr for up to $125 off your mattress order.
Oh lastly,
but certainly not leastly.
Yeah,
certainly not.
Leastly stamps.com stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24,
seven print postage for any male class right from your own computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay.
You did.
I would tell you guys,
I majored in communications.
Let me try my,
my broadcasting voice so I didn't you.
Oh,
here we go.
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business.
stamps.com brings all the amazing services of the U s post office right to your
finger.
Fingertips,
shit by in print,
you official US postage for any letter,
any package in a class of mail using your own computer or printer stamps.com
makes it so easy.
Even your stupid kid can do it.
They'll send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates the exact postage,
stamps.com leave and help you decide the best class of mail based on your needs.
You can even take your daughter and put her on the scale and weigh or just to
see if she's light enough to be a cheerleader.
Um,
no need to lease an expensive postage meter and there are no long term
commitments.
And right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with the special offer
that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale scale.
Sorry,
go to stamps.com.
Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com enter bar there.
Go.
Now let's get onto the questions for this week.
Question Number One,
am I too fat to be a cheerleader?
MMM.
If I continue to take it in the face,
will that extra protein make me beautiful enough?
These are the hard hitting questions in cheerleading.
All right,
Paul Barzee special.
Hey Bill,
I just watched the Paul bursaries forsee special and just wanting to thank you
for promoting it.
Look at that.
It was hilarious and I can't wait for the next all things comedy special on
comedy central.
Keep up the great podcast.
You Maniac.
Oh yeah.
Paul Versey special did very,
very,
very well.
So I want to thank everybody for watching that.
Um,
versus v I.
E.
R.
Z.
I,
I'm sure they got it streaming on their website.
You know how those guys are.
Everybody knows what they're doing over at comedy central.
And I'm,
Paul is just the first week we're going to,
we've got three more specialists come in.
Um,
and we're picking all comics at other comics like and um,
I'm very proud of the group that we have come in.
I'm not allowed to say who they are when I can.
I will.
All right.
That's it.
Advice for all of oil.
Yeah.
Olive oil.
Uh,
number one.
Benito.
Billy.
I'm another 22 year old
lady
and longterm lover of the podcast and truly all of your work.
To be honest,
as an Amazonian myself,
just shy of six feet.
Oh this is for that woman who wrote in olive oil.
Um,
I wanted to reach out and offer some advice to my girl olive oil from last week.
I co sign everything you said about loving yourself and some guy will love you
just the way you are.
But I just wanted to put my 2 cents of advice in as well.
Joel,
Jesus,
get on with it.
There,
which is lift some weights.
Girl.
Thankfully my prayers were answered around the time I reached adulthood in the
form of a nice little waist to hip ratio and suggest praise God.
But I was never satisfied with my rear end and tell it.
I met my husband who is jacked and he introduced me to pumping iron and iron and
Schwartzenegger blesses hard,
taught me how to sculpt an ass out of muscle.
I suggest she watches that movie.
Starts with the basic no supplements except create team weight gainer and
coffee.
Don't waste money on any of the bullshit GNC concoctions and find some heavy
stuff to lift in the following ways.
Squad bench deadlift.
Uh,
now she will get so much self confidence out of becoming stronger than she has
ever been.
I would just say get a personal trainer too.
So you doing all of this right?
You don't fuck up your back.
Um,
and with,
uh,
the endorphins from exercise plus the changes in her body adding mass,
I really think she will love it.
Number two,
the tall,
skinny girl,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is this doing to hear guy?
Don't want to update now clicking,
no,
sorry.
Number two,
the tall skinny girl who wrote in a should move to New York and be worshiped.
I feel for her though,
because people used to tell me stuff like that to my face all the time.
They would just tell them you're calling you stretch,
you know?
Well,
I know the type of type of shit,
you know,
eight foot or whatever they say to tall women.
I don't know.
I don't remember.
It's been a long time since I had been in school.
A 100% of those people who said that to me 10 years ago are now pretty Chubby at
30.
While I look like the same slash better than I did at 20.
My boyfriend says I'm a 10 and he's a catcher and a half.
Uh,
I just looked up
GG Haddad's numbers,
five,
10 and a half tall,
130 pounds,
almost the exact same as this girls.
She should also look into squats,
leg lifts and protein.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
So I think what she did was she embraced her body and made it the best she
could.
She could be.
I think that's all great advice.
Olive oil.
I hope you listen.
All right.
But,
uh,
only thing I would add to that,
just make sure you get a personal trainer,
get a nutritionist and all that stuff and they have the answers rather than
fucking looking at the dope next to you being like,
what,
what are those
knows breakers?
Do they enjoy you?
Try Ya.
I'll fucking,
I'll do,
I'll just do that.
Um,
yeah.
Alexa at my hospital.
Oh Gee judge.
Dear bill,
I work in a medical center that is very up to date with technology in Beverly
Hills that I will not name my work involves me visiting patients at their
bedsides.
I walked into one of my patients from defined Alexa,
mounted on the wall with an example question typed up on a piece of paper.
Alexa,
call my nurse.
My reaction was she has a big fucking Emoji.
Looks like a smiley face.
Oh,
you freaking out.
Is that a freaking out smiley phase?
I don't know.
And I asked the RN that's registered nurse.
Uh,
we have Alexa now.
As soon as I said Alexa,
it lit up with that creepy blue ring waiting for me to give it a command.
I have no idea why patients need that.
And then room,
because patients have remotes that call the nurse station.
Yeah.
Cause it's spying on you.
That also controls the TVS.
I immediately thought of you and chuckle.
Love your work.
And I agree a lot with you lady MD.
See that this smart ladies go with the freckles and you should go with those
freckles.
A celebrity podcast.
Podcasts are this Tuesday in the voting booth.
I say you vote for me.
Me,
me,
me.
Yeah,
yeah,
yes.
I saw them make rib advertised recently.
Must be voting season again.
Hilarious.
Um,
yeah,
that's all creepy.
You know,
flew in and out of Boston from Newark Airport and they had this magazine.
This was trivial to Burt Reynolds.
So it was like,
you know,
I,
it was great.
His movies,
his stunts,
the women he loved.
I was like,
oh,
I gotta read this fucking Burt Reynolds.
They're not gonna make another guy like this.
And,
um,
I,
I go,
I pick up the magazine,
I'm looking around.
There's nobody there.
So I walk over to the restaurant,
I go,
where do I pay for this?
And The lady just goes,
oh,
at the self checkout right over there,
sweetheart.
And she points over to whether it had to been 5 million fucking things.
So I just said,
oh,
okay.
It's right over there.
Okay,
well thank you sweetheart.
And I just walked over to the rack and I fucking put it back in.
I'm not doing it.
Not fucking doing.
That's another thing too.
I've fucking refused to be my own cashier
drawing the line in the sand.
I will.
I will fucking eat a Goddamn thanksgiving meal before I go to the fucking
airport.
I'll bring my reader's digest.
I'm going to be that old guy,
right?
I don't like new things.
And you know what?
No one's going to care,
Bill.
Nobody's going to care.
So just learn how to check yourself out in the mirror.
No silly at a store.
All right,
my wife cheated on me by downloading Tinder and sending nudes.
Hey,
Billy balls.
But listening to your podcast for a few years now in your advocacy,
this is somebody who never would have cheated in the past.
They just were around a computer too long.
I'm telling you,
it's like just having a heroin sitting on your table.
Eventually you're going to do some dumb anyways unless you podcast for a few
years now and your advice always makes me laugh and hard times.
Here's something that just happened to me this past week.
I was hoping you could help me out with,
I got married Memorial Day irony,
um,
of this year.
My wife has been acting really distanced lately and on Sunday I asked her if she
was seeing anyone.
She told me no,
I've known this girl for four years now and I knew she was lying.
Wow.
Do great instincts.
If you guys just gotten married in May,
this is five months later,
it's gone.
This has gotten this bad.
When I asked to look at her phone,
she quickly deleted something and refused to let me see your phone physically
attacking and scratching to keep me from seeing it.
She then admitted to downloading Tinder.
About two weeks ago and has been take talking to a guy and send him some
pictures,
claiming to never have met him and I believe her.
I've been struggling these last few days with a lot of emotions.
It's only five months into the marriage.
Is it best to look at getting a divorce?
It would take a lot of time to forget about what she did.
Especially since I will never really know what transpired.
Saw you in AC and loved it.
Thanks to go fuck yourself.
Yeah,
Dude.
You five months in,
look,
if you were like 10 years in,
you going through a rocky period and I dunno,
you have a couple of kids,
it's something you work out maybe.
But
yeah,
this just seems like if this is happening this early on,
I don't,
she wanted to marry.
That's what I would add.
Or doesn't want to be married or I don't know.
What are his sabotage in the whole thing.
And at that point it's like,
well,
hey,
here's Kudos to you because you did it.
Yeah,
I would get the fuck out of that.
Yeah.
I mean as a kid,
did you dream?
Does that,
was that your dream woman?
Five months in senator or fucking hoo ha over.
There's some funny,
I don't think it is.
Um,
yeah,
I would,
I would get the fuck out of that.
They know not to mention.
She also like physically attacked it too.
So I mean,
I don't know that's got this,
there's a lot of that sounds like the beginning of one of those uh,
lay appear to be a happily married couples.
Occasionally he would showed up with odd scratches and bruises,
but he quickly explained it away saying he was working on his car.
Then one day he didn't show up for Thanksgiving.
His wife had recently been digging a well in the backyard.
All right.
Hate fat people.
Oh Jesus.
Dear Billy bitty balls.
Billy Betty balls.
Oh,
Billy Betty balls once a matter.
Um,
I'm a 20 year old sophomore in college and I have a dilemma like the subject
says fat people really just discussed me.
Oh,
the subject.
Kate Fatty bar.
Uh,
there are too many examples to name,
but one that really gets me is this lady.
My math class,
who sits next to me and we'll ram randomly start smacking her lips and making
this,
yeah,
he spelled it m e h e m.
M noise.
Mm hmm.
She's doing that.
Maybe she's thinking about food.
I don't know.
There was also this guy in my hall who shits literally three times a day.
Well,
it must be rapping as pizza and Kale or something because I see him go to two is
rum with pounds of food at a time?
My dislike isn't anything malicious and I just can't help it,
but I just stuck between a rock and a squishy place and surrounded on all sides
by the fatties.
I know this does not seem like a big,
that big of a deal,
but I have a bit of a temper and I'm afraid I'm going to say something to one of
the fatties and get title nine right out of my school.
Do you have any tips to become a bit more tolerant?
Uh,
I love the podcast.
Congrats on your role in front runner.
You should grow that mustache and keep it and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I did grow that mustache.
I grew that mustache when I had,
when I played the cop way back on Chappelle show.
Um,
let's see here.
Uh,
I would just make a joke out of it.
How well do you know the guy who's always disappeared?
Okay,
I will give him a sumo wrestler name.
Now you can't do that.
That's me.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I know.
It's like a,
yeah,
you're supposed to be tolerant,
but they just continue to eat and they make weird noises and they smell and
you're supposed to just sit next to him and be like,
well,
I feel bad from,
they have a fucking problem.
You know,
it's hard to feel bad for someone that you know,
is gluttonous I guess.
But that's just the way I'm wired.
Like a,
you know,
all of these fucking addicts and all these goddamn people.
Like,
I dunno,
once you live with the fucking attic,
you just,
uh,
yeah.
You just have,
you don't have a lot of patients from,
I don't really know what you're asking me,
so I understand what you're saying.
Um,
I would just find somebody else in shape and I would just together just make fun
of them without them being able to hear it,
you know?
And most of the time they're chewing anyway so it drowns out there hearing.
So I think you'll be all right.
I would just make jokes like that.
Other than that,
what are you supposed to do?
You know?
Um,
I dunno.
Sing songs when they go by.
Okay.
That'd be funny if he just snapped.
Yeah.
Like Jesus Christ again.
How fat are you trying to fucking dead?
You can't do any of that.
And the thing is is you're not really helping them.
You shouldn't fat shame people,
but like,
it's also like,
you know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
there's a little bit of arsenic and an apple,
but it's still good for you.
Like,
yeah,
if you could have like the same level of arsenic that's in an apple,
if you could have that level of shame shaming and fat people,
I think it would help them out a little bit.
Why don't you tie one of them to your bumper and drag them to the gym?
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't want to have the answers here.
Um,
recipe from vegetable Lasagna.
I have no fucking idea why I'm getting this.
Speaking of which,
um,
I have not been eating well.
I consider myself a fat fuck right now and I fetch.
I'm,
I'm a self contained unit.
I will,
I will fat shamed myself.
Um,
or you guys could do it too.
You know,
I always enjoy that.
All right.
Recipe for vegetables on your dear bill.
I was recently listening to an old podcast where you and you were talking about
a thanksgiving.
Oh God.
Yes.
Well you made a shitty vegetarian lasagna with carrots in it.
It was horrible.
Oh my God.
Is one of the worst thanksgivings ever.
Uh,
made me think of a great Broccoli lasagna recipe that my roommate and I would
cook
and I would cook.
Um,
he's at battalion from Sicily.
Oh,
those guys don't consider themselves Italians.
They consider themselves Sicilian and the recipe is from his Italian
grandmothers.
See you know,
it's going to be some good shit.
Uh,
this isn't healthy at all.
It's rich and creamy and absolutely delicious as a Lasagna should be.
Also,
it's super easy.
I can't remember the exact measurements for each thing,
but we're going to try anyways.
Oh,
your protection.
The recipe,
why he gave me was the fucking ingredients.
What does this a cooking show?
700 grams of Broccoli,
Florence
flour,
butter and milk for the bechamel sauce.
Look up a basic lasagna recipe for Beckham,
B,
c,
h,
a m,
e l and amount of Lasagna sheets.
A few cloves of garlic,
chopped olive oil,
fresh Mozzarelle,
a
Parmigiano Reggiano,
tablespoon of Pesto,
depending on how much back on mail you make.
Let's see.
It's pretty simple.
Like all great Italian dishes.
All right.
I'm not gonna read all of this shit.
Cut Up the Broccoli.
All right.
I Dunno if somebody can figure that fucking shit out.
Uh,
anyways,
if I've done an hour,
I think I have.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
I don't know who's playing on any football tonight,
but I gotta do some spots tonight and tomorrow to make sure I'm ready for
Tuesday and into this weekend.
And um,
yeah,
I'm actually going to do something that all old men like to do.
I'm going to take a fucking nap.
I can't wait.
And you guys,
you have no idea how difficult it is to be me.
You know,
dealing with hard hitting problems like cheerleading.
Should we let women cheerlead I love how their cheerleading five feet away from
guys who are literally doing irreparable brain damage to themselves,
most of whom,
you know,
when they get to a certain point,
either go crazy or kill themselves,
but,
but let's,
let's not focus on that.
Um,
anyways,
that's the podcast.
Everybody.
Yeah,
I'll check it on you on Thursday and a,
I don't know what,
I guess now I'm down to watch and uh,
I'm going to start watching the Celtics and the Bruins now when I get fucking
home to my,
my,
uh,
what is center ice package and what do they call the basketball when the NBA
hardcore package.
I don't know what the fuck it is,
is packaged to a,
is that micro aggressive?
My,
uh,
sunrise vagina?
Is that what you're supposed to say?
I have no idea.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves,
please.
Everybody.
Just,
just for me and my celebrity podcasting ego.
Could you get out there and vote because tomorrow is really,
really important.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you Thursday.